my name is Bianca I'm from the
University of Aberdeen I'm presenting
today our new masters and data science
and how we set it up the presentation is
together with Professor marketeer
today I'm going to talk a bit about our
master and data science which we
recently started in Aberdeen and what we
discussed what we considered when we set
this degree up and this talk is by
myself beyond shelter and a colleague
mark O'Neill who is in the audience as
well so if you have questions feel free
to ask either of the two of us I know I
need to finish on time because there is
the most next most important thing in
this conference or one of the most
important things the coffee breaks so
I'll make sure that I finish on time
that's the abstract I think I won't read
it out loud and just continue with our
ideas so what we wanted that master data
signs to be is a real hands-on one-year
degree so they really should touch data
they should work with actual data not
simulated data industry data research
data and and learn how to process it so
from how do I collect the data all the
way to how do I present the results we
intentionally wanted to accept a wide
range of backgrounds and interests so
people from all areas there wasn't you
don't you didn't need a bachelor in
mathematics or physics or something any
background is fine because data science
is relevant in all areas so we invited
them all in and that also meant that a
lot of these students didn't have prior
programming skills so that's one of the
challenges we had to face and that's
obviously one of the reasons why we
chose the world from language rather
than python our MATLAB and whatever else
is out there C C++ I'll come back to
this point repeatedly so that's one of
the key things yeah that's the next
point also the entire degree is taught
in the Wolfram language we obviously
show them that there's a Python
interface that there's an our interface
and so on
but the focus is really on the Wolfram
language because that allows us to teach
this degree in a highly interactive way
so it's not like
would prepare the normal slides we do
that obviously so if there are no
questions we can follow the standard way
of teaching but if there are lots of
questions turned out to be that's really
what's happening they keep asking we
almost start with a blank notebook and
they keep asking question and then we we
know what we need to teach in all the
individual molecules but that allows us
to respond and show them really this is
how we would do it it has another
advantage that they see that we make
mistakes because we have that just
discuss that at this conference
repeatedly as well you have this polish
presentation they all look fantastic
they're all nice they've they work
everything works straight away and if
you do that to students they look and
say oh that's magic because when they
try they make mistakes something doesn't
work and then they said nobody taught us
what to do now and if you start
programming it yourself you get it wrong
you make mistakes they have an immediate
okay if that happens to them it's okay
if it happens to us and also they can
see how we go about these mistakes and
how we would try to to fix them so it's
really it needs to be more like as a
spoken language if you learn language
you wouldn't normally say okay okay
Latin might be an exception
teach me that grammar teach me the words
I go home I translate this text and
tomorrow I'll give you my best possible
translation if you learn English or if
you learn French Spanish you wouldn't do
it this way you would just start
speaking you would do you would start
doing it in order to learn it and that
was one of the big ideas underlying this
degree so we really tried to teach the
teachers and the students in this
interactive way so that they really have
this hands-on life experience hmm I try
to click it worked one of the key things
obviously is when you set up such a
degree there are competitors out there
so before we could even start the
university would ask us is there a
market for that and how big is that
market and so we went with their help
and checked for various institutions
what their programs are called and how
many students they are and you see they
are like the University of Edinburgh
they have quite a big number of students
but
there are also lots of degrees which are
similar to a master's in data science
with fewer students over the years and I
can even scroll through that quite
quickly because this graphical
representation is probably nicer than
reading all these numbers so these discs
basically show you how many students
there are on these degrees and just for
those who don't know Aberdeen is around
there I hope you can see that yes so we
are in the north east corner of the
United Kingdom even northeast of
Scotland as one of the bigger cities
still there and so the question is are
we competitive what can we do what
degree do we need in order to to attract
a large number of students for a data
science degree if you look at a bit more
detail and ask and you don't need to be
able to read the the X label but that's
sort of the distribution of universities
and how many students in data science
related degrees they can cater for and
you see left is University of London so
they have the capacity to cater for
roughly what is that number 240 students
or so and then it drops quite rapidly
Edinburgh is quite up here by the way
London might be represented a couple of
times beakers - University College of
London days University of London and so
on but this is basically the numbers in
data science related degrees if you then
check that's taken I just click II and
hope it works
these are rankings for Great Britain and
you see the university name and it's
ranked by various various criteria
student satisfaction and so on and the
question is has that an influence on the
student numbers and if you look at this
plot you clearly see that there is this
link between the rank and the student
numbers
you can even fit and the word linear is
a bit misleading there because we
changed it ultimately to a nonlinear
model you can even fit a nonlinear model
to this data and you basically say 60
students a sort of capacity and then it
drops and if you go for the ranking of
the University of Aberdeen in the UK
which is 29 maybe I shouldn't advertise
that so much but still for a small city
it's quite quite good you see that we
can cater for top something like or we
can expect from the ranking we have 40
students so ranking is an important
factor in all that if you look a bit
further what's the degree titles and how
they cluster that's a cluster plot and
you see degrees and statistics in the
upper left corner for instance which
have smallish number of students 15 to
20 and if I don't know where I need to
click but if I go over some of those
machine learning 60 these are then the
the outlier sort of these degree of the
programs that have huge numbers yeah
it's just the clustering of yeah yeah
and the last question we had is how do
we name the degree so we looked at thus
the name Mehta do we need to call it
data analysis data analytics data
science and you see most of the curves
are quite flat the data analytics one I
think that is is growing a bit so data
science seem to be data analytics seem
to be a sensible title the first thing
then we did we put the degree as part of
our program on the webpage er students
applied and the students came in and we
use web forms to interact with the
students get their feedback but we also
used it to get to know them so if I
click here you have these interactive
maybe I can make that bigger yes you
have these interactive questionnaires
where you can ask certain things so
what's your highest degree qualification
what are you interested in and so on
and if I go back here yeah cost it
depends so that's that's where the
Scotland is or the University has pretty
clear rules how much they would charge
so for local students the fee is
different from international students
and local students can even if I'm not
mistaken can get scholarships from or
get it for free basically and it needs
to be then or paid for by the Scottish
Government in our case international
students are more expensive but that's
sort of fixed there's no no wiggle room
for us to change that so that's
basically what they determine so if we
then go and ask about these things so
how is your mass kill how is your
programming skill we get the following
results for our students so programming
skills as expected with that variety of
backgrounds is rated by the students
themselves very low so again emphasizing
we need an intuitive programming
language we can't tell them program that
in C++ or C sharp because they will in
finite amount of time struggle to get to
a result and the Wolfram language
obviously allows the flexibility so that
they can get immediate success that I
again get results quickly we ask them
what is your interest so what do you
basically want to do what do you want to
do afterwards what do you want to learn
here and what's encouraging I think is
the terms data analysis machine learning
Big Data but also data management show
up as the highest ranking interests and
that's obviously very important to
become a data scientist to have the
ability to deal with all this but you
again see movies languages music economy
politics so they are really then in
their special areas interested in
various different fields of application
again showing the diversity but also
showing you need a language which which
you can Kate
for all of those quite easily which
backgrounds to the idiot they have most
of them came from engineering geo
sciences and economics and then there's
the other areas you can see there and we
also asked do you have any comments what
do you want basically any other comments
and you see a lot of these feedback that
we got and that's a sample of that
understanding the topic of data science
understanding how to use data and data
analysis so they really came as expected
to learn data science last thing where
did our students come from and this map
shows that we have a quite nice coverage
of the world obviously could always be
better but they come from all over the
world in parallel we started to do also
research into computational thinking so
we start with the teaching but at the
same time we start the research project
so what is the new teaching strategies
how do they work is computational
thinking for that working how successful
are we how well works the the Wolfram
language the new initiatives into sort
of mathematical data science learning
how well does that all work and that's
basically the the letter that says we
are allowed to do that and it's part of
a bigger picture because we started that
not only on the university level but we
started that going out to nurseries all
the way up to university level and
influencing the science stem curriculum
if you wanted to put this way this is
how the degree looks like so why study
data signs I think it's it's pretty
obvious and there's lots of reasons it's
a field of high demand at the moment
it's it's you can do the computational
access for all X's as Stephen Wolfram
set on day one so
a lot of interest there the syllabus of
our degree you basically see in these
different modules and we have a total of
seven more like teaching modules but
this teaching really means interactive
it's not that we present a notebook and
they can't ask questions it's really
they ask the question we also start as I
said with a blank notebook and the
topics covered is introduction to
programming which is introduction to the
Wolfram language it's similar to Gen 101
but in this interactive way then we have
introduction to data science what does
that mean that really goes through the
whole process showing them how to get
from data to something that is an output
that I can interpret and how do I
interpret that and what does that mean
and how do the next steps look like then
there is a module on machine learning
then statistics and time series analysis
data visualization then we have the more
advanced statistics concepts in model
numbers module number six audio image
and video analysis seven and then there
is this which is a bit special
I think case studies where we really
bring in research from our university
but also guest lectures who show really
worked examples yeah the company X came
to me with that question I got that data
and that's how I did it by the way the
concept of guest lectures is also very
important so we try to invite people
from industry we invite colleagues to
present so that they hear firsthand what
industry what stakeholders and what
colleagues are working on and interested
in and then the last thing is they have
to do their project over the summer a
couple of months and then that's what
completes the degree
no no yeah agreed so we need to do that
all in a year and we decided because
they built on each other so the
introduction to the Wolfram language is
the first thing and without that how do
you use the Wolfram language in the next
step so we decided to do this as block
tort modules each of them are three
weeks long and then two of them are more
or less with interactive teaching and
then the third one is the the real
hands-on tutorials doing it but these
tutorials and hands-on sessions are in
parallel in the first two as well but
the third is really dedicated to to
allow them to to work on these things
themselves obviously and that's
questions we heard here a couple of
times at this conference as well why the
Wolfram language and that was the
question that was also asked by the
students so why do we not learn Python
or our because if you look at job drop
AdWords they typically say knowledge in
PI's nor are so why will from language
and this first graph shows the code
efficiency so how quickly can you get to
something and they're obviously
mathematic is Mathematica is much more
powerful than all the others but on top
of that the immediate access the direct
access to this powerful code base so
that you can get to results quickly they
asked us can we make that even more
tutorial driven even more practical so
it's really no more a discussion like in
the language rather than showing them
obviously we need to show them some of
the commands and say that's the
functions that's what they do
but then it is typically embedded in the
discussion so that they really see why
it's useful and and where do they come
from rather than showing them learn this
function learn this function learn this
function and we show you at some point
what to do with it they asked for even
more practicals and they asked for guest
lecture
is from experts or from industry that
show that it's really relevant and we
incorporate that into the degree as I
speak the technology used all lectures
are recorded the setup is ready for
off-site delivery so in principle we can
broadcast it but at the moment it's in
the room but everything is is recorded
we even have short how-to videos for
specific questions that are repeatedly
asked an FAQ in a video mode so that
they can come back and say we have not
understood the import function and what
options I have so there's a short video
dedicated to that the tools used are
ranging from zoom co-chair all the way
to pushbullet to interact with the
students and the students with us
datasets just briefly other than the
ones that are available in the Wolfram
language directly we use data from the
cattle from Amazon Cloud [ __ ] Atlas
statistic are us land viewer to really
work on real data sets out there so that
they get the hands-on experience this is
how actual data looks like as I already
said we hope and you will see that in
half an hour I think that correct there
is this computational conversation
session but you really see that you can
use the Wolfram language to discuss a
topic based on actual code based on
actual data and not based on some claims
that people make so that will be in half
an hour
we do live coding at hands gladiator
fights which is basically who can solve
a problem more efficiently faster
whatnot and that person then goes to the
next level and so on we address current
events the small how-to videos I really
already mentioned Skype office hours and
all the lectures are recorded and
potentially transcribed and in the last
30 seconds I just wanted to give a brief
example how this works and these are
obviously not advanced
all right five minutes good these are
not advanced examples but just shows you
what we do in order to engage them and
order to to keep their interest so the
first one is if I click on that sort of
game where they learn about random
events and random numbers it basically
asks them can you try to send us a
random sequence make up numbers and send
them to us at we will check if they are
really random and as we all know humans
are not very good at this so if I
download that that's one example one way
of looking at that is for instance to
calculate the entropy of these random
numbers and the number we get here is
roughly two point one six I think you
need to remember that because of the
font size but if we then compare that to
actual distributions of random numbers
so really we generate the random numbers
hands-on let's do it
estimate the smooth kernel distribution
of these numbers plot them and you see
this number here is 2.2 - this number is
2.3 - the ones they produced is 2.15
that's probably somewhere here so if you
ask in the last line what is the actual
probability that this number is from
this distribution of entropies and the
answer is zero so that's not a random
sequence and they learned this now first
hand they can program it they can play
with it they can generate these results
and see immediately the feedback how a
computer can for instance decide did you
produce random numbers or not the
account
I should click on that is is the idea
you hide clues on webpages you let them
solve a problem and then they will get
to the next webpage which again has
solve a problem that gets you to the
next page and so on obviously I can't do
that now in the remaining know it's
really true three minutes
to run through that in in real-time but
this is for instance one of the
questions welcome to the next level
download the data from this cloud object
and this list of numbers can give you a
QR code if you represent it in the right
way and if you click on that obviously
it's not really helpful it has a
sequence of zeros and ones and if you
just scroll through it it obviously
doesn't contain much information so
going back to mathematic they need
various skills to solve this task so the
first is read the day time yeah how do i
import the data from the web they
obviously have seen that they need to
realize that when you do that it comes
in as a string so you want that as an
expression to get the zeros and ones
back and then you get this list and then
one way of doing it is for instance just
look at the manipulate of that and if I
shift that here to the right and find
the right m then they get a new barcode
and this barcode gets them to the next
webpage and if they solve that then they
should get to the same command again
next up is gone yeah it is
don't know what happens there but it
didn't do it did it did it did so you go
to the next if you click on that barcode
you see it points you to Dropbox and
asks you to open these two images and
when I open these images then it's a
quite famous picture and the question is
what do we do now they have two of them
you might say yes let's go to the other
one
and that doesn't open we have that
problem yesterday and I don't know why
but what you would have seen is that so
they get pretty much the same picture
there's visibly no difference between
the two and even if you go naively and
say let's take these two and calculate
their difference the answer is it's not
much in it
but if you then know a bit more about
Mathematica and for instance the image
adjust command you see that there is a
Harbor bar code hidden in tiny little
differences in the black color that
basically say what you should do to get
to the next web page and if you scan
that with your phone you will see it
gets you to the web page that in this
case says welcome to the end of this egg
hunt you won the gold neck and with that
and 16 seconds left and the coffee break
starting soon
I stopped here thank you for your
attention and happy to answer questions
[Applause]